INSTITUTIONS COMMITTEE HEARING
TODAY- WE'RE GONNA STOP TO
QUORUM AND SECRETARY PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL. BRADFORD EASIER
THANK CABALLERO ALI IT ALSO.
HUESO PORTANTINO GOT A QUORUM.
ROOM IS ESTABLISHED WE HAVE TWO
ITEMS DAY HERE TODAY AND
HOPEFULLY BE FAIRLY QUICK I SEE
WE HAVE OUR AUTHOR WITH OF A C.
R. ONE FIFTEEN ASSEMBLY WOMAN
COM LONGER YOU PREPARE TO MAKE
THE PRESENTATION. YES FOR HIM.
YOUR FOR ME. THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIR AND- HAPPY NEW YEAR TO.
ALL OF YOU. ILLUSTRIOUS
SENATORS. GOOD AFTERNOON I'M
HERE TO PRESENT ACR ONE ONE
FIVE IT URGES BANKS THAT HAVE
OPENED DEMAND ACCOUNTS WITH THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA THAT'S BANK
OF AMERICA CITIGROUP JPMORGAN
CHASE UNION BANK U. S. BANK
CORPS AND WELLS FARGO AMONG
OTHERS TO RECONSIDER THEIR
LENDING PRACTICES AND STOP
LENDING TO GUN MANUFACTURERS IT
IS AN ESTIMATED THAT THE UNITED
STATES EXPERIENCED
APPROXIMATELY ONE MASS SHOOTING
EVERY FIFTEEN DAYS AND TWENTY
NINETEEN. I SHOOTING IN GILROY
WAS FELT BY ANY THROUGHOUT OUR
COUNTRY BUT PARTICULARLY HERE
IN CALIFORNIA. SINCE LAST
SESSION ENDED WE EXPERIENCED
ANOTHER MASS SHOOTING. IN
FRESNO WHICH LEFT FOUR KILLED
AND SIX INJURED. AND SO FAR
THIS YEAR THERE HAVE BEEN EIGHT
INCIDENTS IN THE UNITED STATES
IN WHICH FOUR OR MORE PEOPLE
HAVE BEEN SHOT. WE SHOULD ALL
BE COMMITTED TO ENDING GUN
VIOLENCE AND TO DO SO WE SHOULD
ACT ON MULTIPLE FRONTS. WE MUST
LOOK AT OUR HABITS PRACTICES
AND EFFORTS AS CONSUMERS AND AS
PROVIDERS TO SEE HOW WE SHARE A
PART OF THE COLLECTIVE
RESPONSIBILITY FOR THE GUN
VIOLENCE EPIDEMIC. PUBLIC
DISCOURSE REGARDING GUN
VIOLENCE OFTEN FOCUSES ON THE
DEMAND FACTOR THIS RESOLUTION
INSTEAD AIMS TO SHIFT DISCORD
TOWARDS THE PLY. OTHER
INDUSTRIES HAVE TAKEN A STAND
AGAINST GUN MANUFACTURERS DELTA
AIRLINES AND HURTS BROKE WITH
THE NRA FOLLOWING THE PARKLAND
FLORIDA SHOOTING JUST LAST YEAR
DICK'S SPORTING GOODS STOP
SELLING GUNS AND AMMUNITION AT
A HUNDRED AND TWENTY FIVE OF
THEIR STORES. THIS RESOLUTION
IS AN OPPORTUNITY FOR THE
BANKING INDUSTRY TO DO MORE
WHILE THE RELATIONSHIP BETWEEN
BANKS AND GUN MANUFACTURERS ARE
LEGAL WE SHOULD ASK. FINANCIAL
INSTITUTIONS THAT LINDA GUN
MANUFACTURERS GIVEN THE PRESENT
GUN MASHING CRISIS OCCURRING IN
OUR COUNTRY IF THEY CAN DO
MORE. CALIFORNIA ALREADY HAS A
STRONG HISTORY OF MAKING VALUE
BASED DECISIONS AGAINST BANKS
USING DIVESTMENT AS A SOCIAL
ACTION TOOL AFTER YEARS OF
PROTEST THE UC REGENTS VOTED IN
EIGHTY SIX TO DIVEST THREE
POINT ONE BILLION DOLLARS FROM
COMPANIES DOING BUSINESS WITH
THE APARTHEID GOVERNMENT OF
SOUTH AFRICA. IT WAS THE
LARGEST UNIVERSITY DIVESTMENT
IN THE COUNTRY AND IN TWENTY
SIXTEEN THE STATE SUSPENDED
RELATIONS WITH WELLS FARGO
FOLLOWING THEIR ACCOUNT FRAUD
SCANDAL. THE STATE TREASURER
REMOVED WELLS FARGO AS A BOOK
RUNNER ONTO MUNICIPAL BOND
ISSUING SUSPENDED INVESTMENTS
WITH THE BANK AND REMOVE THE
BANK AS THE STATE'S BROKER
DEALER THIS SUSPENSION LASTED
TWO YEARS. AND THEN IN TWENTY
SEVENTEEN CALIFORNIA CITIES
DIVESTED FROM BANKS AND
BUSINESSES INVOLVED IN FOSSIL
FUEL PROJECTS SUCH AS PIPELINES
AND TAR SANDS. SOME BANKS HAVE
ALREADY TAKEN ACT SIMILAR TO
ACR ONE FIFTEEN FOR INSTANCE
CITY BANK BAND RETAILERS USING
THEIR SERVICES FROM OFFERING ON
STOCKS AND SELLING GUNS TO ITS
CONSUMERS. FOR THOSE WHO HAVE
NOT PASSED BACK AND CHECK IN
BANG ERICA THEN CAME OUT WITH A
SET OF RESTRICTIONS ENDING
LOANS TO COMPANIES THAT
MANUFACTURE ASSAULT WEAPONS.
USED FOR NON TERRY PURPOSES.
THESE EXAMPLES SHOW THAT BANKS
CAN BE GUIDED BY THE PUBLIC
COLLECTIVE CONSCIOUSNESS. THIS
RESOLUTION ENCOURAGES FINANCIAL
INSTITUTIONS TO REEVALUATE
THEIR LENDING PRACTICES
PARTICULARLY AS THEY APPLY TO
GUN MANUFACTURERS. WITH ME
TODAY IN SUPPORT IS CASEY
O'CONNOR LEGISLATIVE DIRECTOR
FOR THE OFFICE OF THE
CALIFORNIA STATE TREASURER
FIONA AS WELL AS REBEKAH
MARQUESS OF THE BRADY CAMPAIGN.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR CENTERS
ON THE COMMITTEE- BECAUSE THESE
MOMENTS ADD ON HIS YOUR CAR
LEGISLATIVE DIRECTOR FOR THE
TREASURER SHE SENDS HER-
APOLOGY SHE COULDN'T BE HERE
SHE'S NOT COMMITTEE MEETING
SHE'S CHAIRING THAT RAN OVER
THE ALLOTTED TIME I'M SURE YOU
CAN EMPATHIZE. BUT THE STAGE
MANAGER CALIFORNIA HER. SHE
SAID ON THE CALPERS AND
CULTURES SOMETHING THAT SHE'S
BEEN DISCUSSING FOR QUITE
SOMETIME AND THE US TO HELP.
HER DEPARTMENTS AND AGENCIES
HAVE DEPOSIT ACCOUNTS WITH
NUMEROUS BANKING ORGANIZATIONS
INCLUDING BUT NOT LIMITED TO
BANK OF AMERICA CORPORATION AND
CITIGROUP JP CHASE JP MORGAN
CHASE AND COMPANY UNION BANK M.
U. F. G. U. S. BANCORP ANIMALS
FARGO. EQUALLY IMPORTANT THE
STATE HAS OTHER BUSINESS
RELATIONSHIPS WITH MANY OF
THESE ORGANIZATIONS AS WELL THE
OTHER RELATIONSHIPS ENABLE
CALIFORNIA TO SEPARATE STATE
SECURITIES FINANCE CRITICAL
INFRASTRUCTURE NEEDS. AND
PURCHASE MARKETABLE SECURITIES
SECURITIES FOR THE STATE'S
PULLED MONEY INVESTMENT ACCOUNT
MANAGING THE TREASURER'S
OFFICE. SOME OF THESE BANKS
HAVE BUSINESS RELATIONSHIPS
WITH GUN MANUFACTURERS HIS GUNS
BEEN INVOLVED IN SOME OF THE
NATION'S DEADLY SMASH THINGS
THESE INCLUDE THE AURORA MOVIE
THEATER COLUMBINE HIGH SCHOOL
AT NEW LIFE CHURCH THE TREE OF
LIFE SYNAGOGUE IN PITTSBURGH
SAN BERNARDINO SANDY HOOK AND
SUTHERLAND BRINGS CHURCH. IN
TWENTY EIGHTEEN ALONE. FOR
CALIFORNIA EXPERIENCE MORE THAN
THIRTY MASS SHOOTINGS CAUSING.
OFFICIALS EXAM IT'S US IN
RESPONSE A GROUP OF INVESTORS
IN FINANCIAL MANAGERS PUTTING
CALPERS CAL STIRS STATE STREET
GLOBAL ADVISORS SAN FRANCISCO
EMPLOYEES RETIREMENT SYSTEM AND
NINE OTHERS WITH ASSETS EQUAL
TO FOUR POINT EIGHT TRILLION
DOLLARS CAME TOGETHER TO ASK
THE CIVILIAN FIREARMS INDUSTRY
TO COMPETE. FIVE THESE
PRINCIPLES ARE SENSIBLE AND NOT
INTENDED TO BE PRESCRIPTIVE IN
NATURE COMPANIES ARE FREE TO
APPLY THE PRINCIPLES IN A
MANNER THEY DEEM APPROPRIATE
HOWEVER THERE IS MORE TO BE
DONE BY COMPANIES WITHIN
EXISTING REGULATORY BOUNDARIES
TO ADVANCE SAFETY IN THE
RESPONSIBLE USE OF CIVILIAN
FIRE ARMS. IT'S PRINCIPLES
INCLUDES FOR MORE TRACEABLE
TECHNOLOGY ADOPTION OF
RESPONSIBLE DEALER PRACTICES
THE ESTABLISHMENT OF COMPLETE
BACKGROUND CHECKS AND EDUCATION
AND TRAINING OF EMPLOYEES AT
DISTRIBUTORS. IN ADDITION CAL
STARS DIVESTED FROM REMINGTON
OUTDOOR A GUN MANUFACTURER
CREATING FIREARMS BE IN
CALIFORNIA. THE PENSION FUND
COMMENTED THAT THE DIVESTMENT
OF THE PENSION FUNDS HOLDING
WAS RESULT OF STAYING TRUE TO
THE VALUE OF ITS BENEFICIARIES.
THE STATE TREASURER STRIVES TO
ENSURE THAT THE STATE'S
BUSINESS RELATIONSHIP WITH
BANKS ALIGNED WITH THE STATE'S
VALUES. BY THE SAME TOKEN THE
STATE'S BUSINESS RELATIONSHIPS
BUT THESE BANKS NEEDS TO BE
SUBJECTED TO THOUGHTFUL
DELIBERATION. OF ANALYSIS OF
THE RELATIONSHIPS AND
DEVELOPMENT OF PURPOSEFUL PLANS
FOR MANAGING THOSE
RELATIONSHIPS ACR ONE FIFTEEN
WILL SET THE STAGE FOR
CALIFORNIA TO BEGIN RESEARCHING
AND ANALYZING ITS BUSINESS
RELATIONSHIPS WITH FINANCIAL
INSTITUTIONS LENDING TO GUN
MANUFACTURERS TO ACCOMPLISH
THESE GOALS I AM CONFIDENT THAT
A RIGOROUS DISCIPLINE APPROACH
TO THESE COMMONSENSE PRINCIPLES
WILL PRODUCE GOOD OUTCOMES FOR
ALL CALIFORNIANS WE
RESPECTFULLY REQUEST YOUR AYE
VOTE WHEN IT'S- TIME. THANK YOU.
IT WOULD. TO NOON SHARON
MEMBERS REBEKAH MARKETS
REPRESENTING BRADY UNITED
AGAINST GUN VIOLENCE I'M HERE
TODAY TO ASK THE COMMITTEE FOR
AN AYE VOTE ON A C. R. ONE
FIFTEEN THE PLAYERS IN THE GUN
VIOLENCE CRISIS UNITED STATES
THE GUN MANUFACTURERS PRODUCING
ANYTHING A HANDGUN TO A
MILITARY STYLE ASSAULT WEAPONS
ACR ONE TEEN SAYS THE EXCEPT
FOR THE CALIFORNIA STATE
GOVERNMENT'S BEHIND. EXAMPLE
ARE URGING BANKS TO DIVEST AND
DISTANCE RELATIONSHIPS WITH GUN
MANUFACTURERS IN ORDER IN ORDER
TO HAVE THAT ONE OF THE KEY
FACTOR AGAIN AFTER JANNIK
NEARLY UNLIMITED SUPPLY OF
LOANS FROM BIG BANKS CONTINUE
TO GROW MANUFACTURING RATES FOR
THOSE REASONS IN THE AS ALREADY
STATED I URGE AN AYE VOTE. ON
ACR ONE FIFTEEN THANK YOU. YOU
ANY ADDITIONAL WITNESSES IN
SUPPORT OF THIS RESOLUTION.
SENIOR NINE WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION. XENON. WE NEED TO
THE COMMITTEE ANY QUESTIONS OR
CONCERNS BY THE COMMITTEE.
SENATOR CAFIERO. YOUR CHAIR AND
THEN RUN OUT- RECOGNIZE AND
THANK THE AUTHOR FOR BRINGING
THIS RESOLUTION FORWARD WHEN I
RECOGNIZE IT IF IT IS A
RESOLUTION MAD AT A DISCUSSION
ABOUT. THIS SOME OF OBJECTIVE
CRITERIA BECAUSE- THE
RESOLUTION BASICALLY IS A
LITTLE AMORPHOUS BECAUSE IT
SAYS. THE VALUES OF THAT THE-
MERE THE PEOPLE OF CALIFORNIA'S
VALUES AND- HOWEVER THAT
RESOLUTION DOES HAVE SOME VERY
SPECIFIC. THINGS IN IT THAT.
THAT THIS LEGISLATURE HAS VOTED
ON THAT ARE- PROHIBITED IN
STATE CALIFORNIA PARTICULAR
MILITARY STYLE ASSAULT WEAPONS.
TO THE PUBLIC- A BACKGROUND
CHECKS- STOCK HIGH CAPACITY
MAGAZINES- SO IN OUR
DISCUSSION- SOME OF THAT'S IN
HERE BUT I WAS JUST CONCERNED
ABOUT THE WORDING AND- AND
AFTER SOME DISCUSSION. IT WAS
CLEAR TO ME THAT- WHAT THE
AUTHOR IS INTERESTED IN DOING
IS SPARKING A DISCUSSION WITH
THE SHAREHOLDERS- SO THAT THE
SHAREHOLDERS CAN BE INVOLVED IN
MAKING THE DECISIONS ABOUT WHAT
KIND OF INVESTMENT SHOULD BE
MADE. ON AND ON AND THE ARE- I
THINK REALLY IMPORTANT AND SO I
WANT TO BE ABLE TO SUPPORT THIS
THE AUTHOR HAS BEEN IS
INDICATED SHE'S WILLING TO
TAKE. FROM AN AD THAT STATEMENT
THAT WAS TO HAVE THE
SHAREHOLDERS. PART OF THE
DISCUSSION AND THAT THEY. THAT
IT REALLY GO BEFORE THEM AND
WITH THAT IN MIND I'M PREPARED
TO SUPPORT IT TODAY. QUESTIONS
OR COMMENTS FROM COMMITTEE.
TAKING HIM ON MOTION WE HAVE A
MOTION BY SENATOR. GARAGE AND
IT WE HAVE A DO PASS
RECOMMENDATION TO THE FLOOR
MADAM SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL. WHAT ARE. SOME WOULD YOU
LIKE TO CLOSE I JUST WANT TO
THANK THE SENATOR FOR- GIVING
ME SOME OF HER TIME FOR US TO
HAVE THIS CONVERSATION AN ECHO
SOME OF THE STATEMENTS SHARED-
BY CASEY THAT. IN THIS
RESOLUTION AND IS ABOUT HAVING
FOUGHT FULL DELIBERATIONS IN
CONVERSATIONS IN REAL PLANS
FROM AS MANY INDUSTRIES AS
POSSIBLE BUT SPECIFIC TO THE
BANKING INDUSTRY TO TALK ABOUT
HOW WE HAVE A SHARED COLLECTIVE
RESPONSIBILITY- TO FINDING
SOLUTIONS AND WITH THAT I ASK
FOR YOUR AYE VOTE. THANK YOU.
ANSWER THREE PLEASE COLOR
MOTION IS DUE PASSED TO THE
FLOOR SENATOR BRADFORD HI. I
THANK YOU KNOW PAYING NOW
CABALLERO AYE. AYE ALLEY. RAZA
PRESENT I. SO PORTANTINO.
PORTANTINO I. THREE ONE ONLY
THE MATTER OPENED OUT OF FOUR
ONE ONE OKAY FOR THE ONE THAT
MEASURES OUT AND LEAVE IT OPEN
FOR ABSENT MEMBERS TO ADD ON
THANK YOU ASSEMBLY WOMAN WERE
NOW WAITING FOR OURS NEXT
AUTHOR SENATOR HERTZBERG AND IF
HE'S NOT HERE IN FIVE MINUTES
WE'RE GONNA. WALK OUT ONLY ONE.
YEAH
. DECIDED TO SHOW UP. I WAS
GOAL OF SLOWER BECAUSE THEY TOO
MUCH BIRTHDAY CAKE AT MY
FRIEND'S BIRTHDAY PARTY. WE
DON'T I WOULDSAY WE CAN HOLD
IT. ASHLEY I MIGHT AGREE ON
THAT. I DIDN'T DO IT ON THE
ROAD AGAIN OKAY- WE'RE HERE TO
HEAR ITEM ONCE INNER HERTZBERG
SB FIVE TWO TWO CENTER WHEN
YOU'RE READY YOU MAY BEGIN
FIRST AND FOREMOST LESSON OF
THE DAY IS THAT I GRACIOUSLY
AND PROBABLY EXCEPT THE
AMENDMENTS OF THIS COMMITTEE.
THE RECOMMENDED AMENDMENTS TO
THE ANALYSIS. THIS MEASURE WAS
BROUGHT TO MY OFFICE BY OUR
SECRETARY OF STATE MR BUT THE A
IN AN EFFORT TO TRY TO
STREAMLINE AND- DEAL WITH SOME
OF THE EFFICIENCIES AND
CHALLENGES THAT HE HAS OFFICES
YOU KNOW WE AS MANY
RESPONSIBILITIES BEYOND JUST
VOTING HE DEALS WITH ALL THE
BUSINESS RECORDS AND- WHEN YOU
FILE FOR- ARTICLES OF
INCORPORATION WITH THIS EXTRA
STATES OFFICE SOARED DOCUMENTS
FOR A LIMITED LIABILITY
CORPORATION OR L. L. P. CERTAIN
STANDARDS AND WHEN YOU. THERE'S
SOME CHALLENGE THAT HE BROUGHT
TO OUR OFFICE THAT. THERE'S A
DEER WHEN YOU WHEN YOU GO TO
SEEK TO RESERVE A NAME THERE'S
DIFFERENT STANDARDS THAT ARE
USED DEPENDING UPON WHETHER
IT'S A CORPORATE ENTITY. OR
LIMITED LIABILITY ENTITY AND
WHAT HE'S TRYING TO DO IS TO
AVOID THE EXCEPTIONS TO CONFORM
TO STANDARDS TO MAKE HIS OFFICE
WORK BETTER. AND THAT I WILL
PASS THIS TO THE SECRETARY OF
STATE'S OFFICE TO FURTHER
ARTICULATE THE POSITION. I GOOD
AFTERNOON CHAIRMAN BRADFORD IN
MEMBERS TED WILL HOUSE ON
BEHALF OF SECRETARY STATE ALEX
PADILLA. SECRETARY PRETTY IS
PROUD TO SPONSOR SENATE BILL
FIVE TWENTY TWO WHICH WILL MAKE
IT EASIER TO DO BUSINESS IN
CALIFORNIA. BY ADOPTING A
DISTINGUISHABLE IN THE RECORDS
STANDARD FOR APPROVING NEW
CORPORATION NAMES. THIS BILL
WILL REDUCE THE TIME IT TAKES
TO COMPARE PROPOSED CORPORATE
NAMES AGAINST EXISTING NAMES.
THROUGH AUTOMATION AND OTHER
ANTICIPATED EFFICIENCIES. US
SECRETARY OF STATE'S OFFICE
WILL BE ABLE TO ADD STAFF
RESOURCES NOW TO OTHER. KEY
BUSINESS PROGRAM AREAS AND
IMPROVE CUSTOMER SERVICE. I
WOULD LIKE TO COMMITTEE AND
STAKEHOLDERS FOR SUGGESTING THE
CLARIFYING AMENDMENTS- TAKEN BY
THE AUTHOR. AND REQUEST FULLY
OF RED RESPECTFULLY REQUEST
YOUR SUPPORT THANK YOU.
WITNESSES IN SUPPORT. RIGHT SIR
THE BUSES OUT THAT A LITTLE BIT
LATE THIS COUPLE BUSES COMING
IN SUPPORT JUST LIKE YOU THE
LATE WITH THIS IN OPPOSITION.
SEEN IN HEARING I THINK THE BUS
OF OPPOSITE OPPOSITIONS OUT
THERE TOO THEY'RE RUNNING A
LITTLE LATE SO I'M GONNA I'M
GONNA WAIT ON THEM AS WELL ANY
QUESTIONS BY THE COMMITTEE. THE
BILL HAS BEEN MOVED BY OUR VICE
CHAIR- SENATOR TRYING. I WANT
TO THANK THE AUTHOR FOR THIS
MEASUREMENT THANK YOU FOR
WORKING WITH THE COMMITTEE AND
I. JUST ADDRESSING THOSE TECH-
IMAGE THAT. WE FELT WAS GONNA
MAKE THIS MEASURE A LITTLE BIT
BETTER AND I CLEARLY UNDERSTAND
THE CHALLENGES THAT THIS SECTOR
STATE OFFICE HAVE AN OPEN WE-
DO THIS MEASURE WILL STREAMLINE
THAT PROCESS. WITH THAT WE HAVE
AID TO RECOMMENDATION I MEAN I
DO PASS- WHAT AMENDMENTS TO SEE
SENATE APPROPRIATIONS. YES THEY
WOKE UP PROCESS LIMITS IN A
APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE SO
AGAIN WE HAVE A TO PASS. WITH
THE MINUTES TO BE TAKEN IN THE
SENATE APPROPRIATIONS. MADAM
SECRETARY PLEASE KALRA. MOTION
IS TO PASS WITH AMENDMENTS TO
BE TAKEN APPROPRIATIONS SENATOR
BRADFORD HI I THANK BY I DON'T.
AYE DELI ARE ALSO PRESENT I WAS
SO PORTANTINO. YOU KNOW I.
MEASURES OUT SIX VOTE THANK YOU
SENATOR GRADUALLY SEVEN THANK
YOU VERY MUCH FIVE WE GET TOO
MANY PROBLEMS TODAY SHOW. IF
YOU FIVE BUT IT'S OUT. MEMBERS
THAT CONCLUDES OUR BUSINESS I
WILL LEAVE THE ROLE OPEN FOR A
FEW MINUTES. JUST IN CASE. YEAH
WELL IT'S NO NEED TO KEEP IT
OPEN WE JUST BEEN INFORMED THAT
SENATOR DALLY WILL NOT BE IN
ATTENDANCE AS WELL SO THAT
CONCLUDES OUR BUSINESS- THIS
BANKING AND FINANCIAL
INSTITUTIONS STANDS ADJOURNED.
THANK YOU MEMBERS